coalition with the PVV
never never anything nuclear energy
oe we do again
nuclear energy
not wise for the Netherlands
to laugh at your own blunders
yes,
but I had to learn that
1 coalition with the VVD
rather not take a cold shower
is that nice
no kitty kotti make 1 national holiday
actually 1 good plan
farmers are obliged to buy out
rather not on the line
it should
free childcare
yes and that has to be done very quickly
celebrate your wedding day
yes you never forget
always always forget
literal reflection period for abortion
women should boss his own belly his point
attend concert
yes very much
last was the performance of blue springsteen
in Landgraaf
and huge fan
yes become prime minister
with emphasis